[Musik]
das sei doch verrückt ist die stimme
eines augenzeugen des spektakels im us
bundesstaat georgia zu hören
dort spazierte der alligator am sonntag
seelenruhig über einen golfplatz die
spieler unterbrachen ihre laufende
partie der beherzte videofilmer gab an
alligatoren seien auf dem gelände
durchaus schon gesichtet worden
doch die größe dieses exemplars so etwas
besonderes alle hätten sie sich davon
beeindruckt gezeigt und er habe sich
gedacht sein vierjähriger sohn würde die
aufnahmen sicher lieben selbst die
fortbewegung geräusche seien
faszinierend gewesen dass alles
beeindruckte den alligator star vor ort
natürlich gar nicht er verabschiedete
sich ins erfrischende nass nach angaben
der umweltbehörde leben in georgia
zwischen 200 und 250 tausend alligatoren